welcome again to farm Vibes
[Music]
life in today's video we'll be taking a
detailed look at one of the most beloved
and adaptable fruits
lemons this ingredient is not only a
staple in household kitchens around the
world it also plays an important role in
many different
[Music]
Industries have you ever wondered how
such a tiny fruit can be used in such
remarkable ways let's explore the
fascinating journey of lemons following
them from Harvest to becoming essential
products that we use every
[Music]
day once harvested these fresh fruits
are transported to a sorting facility
marking the beginning of the next stage
in their
[Music]
Journey upon arrival the lemons are
carefully unloaded and sorted according
to Quality this important process
ensures that only the best lemons reach
the store shelves and ultimately your
[Music]
hands any lemons that are bruised
discolored or not up to quality
standards are discarded or reused for
juice or essential oil production lemon
trees are usually propagated by grafting
a technique that ensures the new tree
inherits the best characteristics from
the parent tree the grafting process
begins by selecting a branch from a
mother plant that has the desired
characteristics and attaching it to the
rootstock of another vigorous plant The
Joint point is firmly fixed so that the
two parts canuse together over time the
graft will grow forming a new tree that
grows vigorously and bears fruit earlier
than a tree grown from
[Music]
sea unmanaged lemon grafting specifies
time while improving production
processes to ensure improved energy and
[Music]
quality easy lemon harvesting process
combining age-old methods with modern
advances
[Music]
many farmers still use handpicking
techniques that require special
attention to detail and precision this
Hands-On method allows them to pick the
right moment when the lemons reach ideal
ripeness ensuring the highest
quality the farmer gently plucks the
lemon Blossom from the plant taking care
Not to cause any damage as even a small
scratch can reduce the value and
longevity of the
[Music]
fruit after harvesting lemons are
carefully placed in baskets or buckets
avoiding excessive pressure to maintain
the freshness and quality of each
fruit on larger Farms Machinery is used
to increase efficiency and speed in the
harvesting process these machines
powered by hydraulic or electric motors
gently shake the trees causing the
lemons to fall onto random frames or
conveyor belts this method is highly
efficient and can significantly increase
yields although it is also challenging
because it can damage the tree canopy
once the lemons are harvested they are
transported to a sorting facility where
the next stage of the Journey Begins
upon arrival the lemons will be
carefully unloaded and sorted according
to
Quality this process is important to
ensure only the best lemons make it to
the store shelves and into your hands
any lemons that are stale discolored or
otherwise substandard or discarded are
sometimes used for for other
[Music]
purposes such as juicing or essential
oil
production these sords represent Cutting
Edge technology using artificial
intelligence to identify not only
external flaws but also internal defects
in lemons that are invisible to the
naked eye the system works with
Incredible precision carefully
inspecting each fruit the use of this
advanced technology has significantly
improved the efficiency and precision of
lemon processing optimizing large- scale
production while maintaining the highest
quality standards once sorted the lemons
undergo a meticulous cleaning process
they are soaked in large tanks of water
to remove any dirt debris or pesticide
residue that may be on their surface a
gentle water spray and air blow system
is used to ensure the lemons are clean
without damaging the delicate skin of
the lemon lemons after being thoroughly
cleaned and dried the lemons are
prepared for packaging before being
shipped to wholesale markets lemons are
usually packaged in sturdy spacious
boxes designed to hold large quantities
of fruit while protecting their
integrity these boxes are carefully
packaged to minimize impact and prevent
damage during transit to retail stores
lemons are usually packaged in mesh bags
to allow good air circulation helping to
prolong the shelf life of the fruit
these bags also make handling and
displaying the product easier providing
convenience for both retailers and
consumers in addition to exporting fresh
lemons lemon juice production is growing
[Music]
rapidly once the lemons are cleaned they
are processed using a high- powered
juicer system that extracts juice
quickly and
efficiently this process takes place in
a sterile environment to ensure food
safety after pressing the juice is
filtered to remove pulp and seeds then
sterilized and bottled
automatically the final product retains
its fresh taste ensures high quality and
is ready to serve Global
[Music]
consumers we have just learned in depth
about the Journey of lemon from
harvesting to processing in the
factory we hope this video gives you a
better insight into the complex process
behind making lemon products if you
found this video interesting and
informative please leave a comment to
share your thoughts with
us don't forget to like subscribe and
hit the notification Bell enable
notification Bell to make sure you stay
tuned for all upcoming videos looking
forward to our next meeting
[Music]
he
n
[Music]
a
he
[Music]
he w
he
[Music]
n
he
[Music]
a
oh
[Music]